welcome back to sunday night in america
the charlie daniels band had a hit song
in 1979 titled the devil went down to
georgia
i will not sing it for you because i
don't want to be fired or fined by the
fcc but it went something like this the
devil went down to georgia he was
looking for a soul to steal he was in a
bind because he was way behind and he
was willing to make a deal
i thought about that song this week joe
biden went to georgia because he's in a
bind too
he's had a rough six months the feckless
withdrawal from afghanistan is a stain
on the reputation of this country
we were told biden was the most
experienced president ever in matters of
foreign policy but he left american
soldiers vulnerable
left the american military equipment in
the hands of enemies
left behind those who helped our country
and then his administration fired a
drone into the wrong car killing
innocent children
that's a bad decade but he managed to
pull all of that off in about a month
the border is a disaster covet continues
to ravage the country inflation is
hitting historic highs the supply chain
is damaged schools are closed but the
prisons are open
history is tough on presidents and
midterms but cleo will be especially
hard on this president
biden is poised to lose the house and
the synod he never had a mandate just a
chance to lead a divided country
and he squandered that
less than one year removed from his
inaugural address wherein he talked
about unity to the everlasting delight
of editorial boards across the country
this president is dividing the country
again and using race and voting
it's not hard to vote in georgia it's
actually pretty easy
it's so easy biden won in georgia along
with two democrat candidates for senate
which is why it is so very hard to
understand why he would want to
denigrate one of the few southern states
he actually has a chance to win
but he did
and he used deliberate misinformation to
do it
is it asking too much to show an idea to
vote we show an id to do many things
including gain access to other
constitutional rights and even though
biden knows he's wrong he continues to
repeat the lie that you have to stand in
the voting line without water
you can have all the water you want
you just can't get it from people who
are trying to influence your vote
while you are standing in line
and now biden wants to change the senate
rules so he can federalize elections he
says voting rights are so important the
rules of the senate must be changed
what about the judges who preside over
voting rights cases they're important
too aren't they why not change the rules
for judges
what about the u.s attorneys and the fbi
agents who enforce these laws i mean
what's the use in having laws if they're
not enforced so let's change the senate
rules for u.s attorneys and fbi
directors too
and you need money to enforce and
prosecute voting laws so let's change
the rules for budget and appropriations
while we're at it
biden traveled south to talk about
what he considers anti-democratic
actions
it's actually a much shorter trip to new
york which is where he should have gone
new york is home to a brand new
prosecutor who by email or office memo
has decided to change the law
he's deciding which laws will be
enforced and which ones won't be and
what could possibly be more
anti-democratic than the opinion of one
person
overcoming the will
of a legislative body
the media loves the word anti-democratic
they don't like red states changing
election laws those are all bad because
the media claims to believe in the power
and sanctity of your vote but they have
no problem with the district attorney
negating your vote with a memo or an
office wide email and that's exactly
what's happening
if you are looking for a textbook
definition
for the word anti-democratic
allowing one person to substitute his or
her will for that of the people as
expressed in a duly enacted law
is a pretty good place to start
so the next time president biden decides
to travel to highlight his notion of
anti-democratic actions
he should go to new york not georgia
and take the devil with you
i hear he can now vote in new york
even if he's not a citizen
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis